[Music]
hi everyone I'm Alex York I'm here with
Alia Chanel Scott we are at the Forbes
under 30 Sumit in Cleveland Ohio welcome
we are so excited to have you I'm so
excited to be here so we are at the
under 30 Summit you made the under 30
local list this year what does being
under 30 mean to you my gosh wow I mean
I feel so lucky and grateful and
honestly a little bit of imposter
syndrome but I think that that's normal
hopefully um yeah I think it's
interesting I was doing this interview
earlier on stage and they were like
asking about my aspirations to produce
and and really I said that it was not
anything I dreamt of doing it sort sort
of was something born out of necessity
um and I think that I'm a Problem Solver
and I think that that my my Tendencies
just naturally sort of lean toward the
work that I end up doing and so I don't
really see it as much of an achievement
other than just sort of like what I feel
called to do in my life um but I'm very
grateful and to be surrounded by people
who are so talented I mean Lexi and
Jordan they're amazing and um it's just
such a treat honestly yeah it's super
cool what you guys are working on and
all that you're doing but the
entertainment industry in general has
been around for so long so what is your
advice on breaking into an industry
that's so established were there any you
know key things that you focused on in
order to do so or things that you know
now with the kind of growth that you're
having that you're really working to
change on your end wow um I think that
the wein that I had was through like
training is a very traditional route I
think I was I I wanted to be an actor
and I trained and then I went and I
audition and I got a job and I think
that sort of led me down the spiral of a
larger career and a broader career um
but I think my method really has been
sort of learning the way it works and
then once I learn the way it works
finding the areas that I feel need work
and then focusing in on those and sort
of building from there so my work as a
producer really has been about learning
the industry knowing what works and what
doesn't and then getting in the room and
offering up a younger perspective and
more a more creative Innovative
perspective and and hoping that you know
they bite and that we can sort of shift
the industry as we go along totally but
I think also there's a route where you
sort of make your own lane and you make
your own path and we see that more and
more I just wish I was that Innovative
and that creative off the bat I was not
but um yeah I think that there are
multiple ways in I don't think you have
to to focus on just one way or one One
path to doing it yeah and you talked
about on stage like the Young Generation
today gen Z younger than us really being
so Innovative and entrepreneurial and
you know kind of coming in with our own
ideas our own ways of doing things in
your work how do you find with your
production stuff specifically how does
how do you find it best resonates with
Jen Z Are there specific like values
that you focus on or ways of working or
types of stories that you think really
you know strike Accord with the jenzi
audience yeah I think that we're a lot
smarter than people write us off to be I
think there was a time period where
there's a certain type of content that
they deemed for young people right and
then I think you go on Twitter now and
we see right through that we sort of
have have been fed media our entire
lives to the point where we're experts
at it we get when people are trying to
tell us a story that is maybe one thing
and we see behind that and we call it
out and I think that we need art that is
a little more transparent a little
more just original and Innovative and
creative I think that it's out there I
think people are writing it I just don't
think they're being given the
opportunities to Showcase it on a
broader level in a very Commercial Way
which is sort of my work as a producer
and and really understanding the
business aspect of it so that people
like Jordan who wrote I mean created
ain't no can go to a space like Broadway
and succeed in that space because that's
the sort of art that resonates with us
The Cutting Edge Unapologetic
interesting nuanced um really creative
work we're smart I think as a generation
we are we're smarter than that and you
got to do better in order for us to
really bite uh and I think the the
things that succeed nowadays are things
that find creative smart ways about
doing this doing uh Broadway totally and
a thing that goes across board for all
sorts of Industries with Jen Z but with
your Broadway work and your production
work specifically is there a favorite
project that you've worked on or
something that you're extremely proud of
oh my gosh yes uh one of the very first
things I worked on as a producer was my
best friend Dyan mulany who's also a
friend of Forbes and 30 under 30 she did
uh her day 365 show and she came to me
and said I think I want to do cuz we did
Book of Mormon tour together as actors
and then we both went off and had these
Like Crazy Life Experiences during the
pandemic and now she's a content creator
and business woman and I'm producing and
so she came to me and like what if I
went back on a stage for day 365 like
what would that look like could you help
me do that and it was the first time
that I thought yeah actually like I have
the expertise and the I think I could do
that with you and and working with my
best friend to to create something that
was never never been done before she had
an idea to create a onew woman show that
was written for her and about her like
Journey transitioning over the last 365
days and then it was up to me and our my
producing team to then find way the best
way to support that as a business model
because for her her audience is online
right and so we that begs the question
of like accessibility if we do a live
thing in New York how many people are
going to actually have access to that
it's a real question we have to ask um
and so the way we went about it was
doing a show in New York that was live
and then filming that live captured and
then uh live streaming it online to her
audience and selling I think it was like
$5 tickets in support of the Trevor
Project so we had a like impact partner
and it was just a really
Grassroots kind of way of us being like
how can we do this in a way that makes
sense for us in this moment and not what
has been done time and time again and it
was i' say successful and her goal was
accomplished we raised a bunch of money
for Trevor Project and I walked away
from it being like Oh if this is what I
could do as a producer then I only want
to do this I would love to do this every
single week with my friends with my
peers with people who whose art I
believe in like if I could help them in
that way succeed that makes me feel like
I'm also succeeding as as a business
find a job that you actually just enjoy
doing on a daily basis and it makes it
so much easier to you know go through
the hard days or things like that that
inevitably come along with it what has
been the biggest business challenge for
you speaking of those hard days oh my
gosh well I think producing is a lot
about like and directing as well is
about speaking a bunch of different
languages you when you talk to one
person you have to speak their language
when you talk to another person you have
to speak their language and it's about I
think knowing how to sort of Juggle and
manage all of those and still maintain
sort of like calm air about yourself
because I think if you if you don't have
that that confidence and that security
then the thing melts from the top down
uh so I think for me it's been not
reacting super emotionally when problems
happen and just being sort of strategic
and saying okay how can I we hired
people who do their jobs well how can I
help them do their job well I'm not here
to tell you how to do it I'm here to
support you in doing it and and doing
what I asked of you to do and what you
came here to do and so I think that for
me has been the sort of like biggest
lesson is just in a practical send how
to how to best show up for the people
that you work with definitely if you
could have three words that describe
your leadership style or your kind of
style as a producer as a leader in this
industry what would they be oh um that's
really hard question why would you do
that to
me three words to
describe I think I'm transparent I think
when I don't know something I tell you I
don't know it and I think that that has
helped me in every case that it that it
could it's better to say actually I'm
not sure how to do that maybe someone
else could better help you than to try
to like pretend like you know what's
going on um that has helped me and then
I
think loyalty I think there are people
who you meet early on I'm I love
networking but I love networking across
I love meeting people who are on the
same Journey as me and sort of helping
each other get get there together um and
of course you need the support from
those like older Generations but really
it's about like how can I hone my
community um and then just I'm really
goofy like I really truly love to get in
a space and be like you guys what are we
doing here today like I don't know let's
figure it out and I think that that sort
of calms the energy of the thing down
and we don't take ourselves too
seriously and that we just we all have
the common goal of like making the thing
and making it well um and so I think
knowing that everyone's on the same team
and just being able to like relax and
play a little bit um has helped me
totally do you have any either producers
or actors or people in the industry that
you have really looked up to as you have
been coming up I mean a million people
I'm that's the hardest question in the
world I think Issa is someone who I've
always watched and been like how did she
at every point in her career just like
stay so authentic and true to herself
and ask people to show up for her and
and and sort of be like okay I'm here I
know I have something good do you want
to be a part of it or not I think that
that takes so much confidence and I I
really admire her and everything she's
been able to do with her production
company and and with insecure I think
that that's like the dream um and
honestly like my friends I truly look up
to the people around me and the people
that I work work with my producing
partner Thomas La is like one of my best
friends we met in college and he is
someone that I think is about what he
says he's about and I think that I when
I trust that someone is about what they
say they're about I'm inspired by them
it doesn't you don't have to be the most
successful person in the world I think I
think the people that inspire me most
are people who show up and and are are
honest and real and and good people yeah
no I love that and my last question for
you is what is next for you for Rion
land your production company for any
other project projects you have coming
up what are you what's on the horizon
what are you excited for in the next
couple months or couple years well right
now in Cleveland I saw last night we
were producing on the whz which is
touring and then headed to Broadway next
year which is a phenomenal show if you
can catch it you should on Broadway
right now we have Gutenberg the musical
which is Josh Gad and Andrew rold a
two-hander it's a comedy it's it's doing
really well we open next week so it's
been kind of crazy but very fun and then
we have a couple other things that are
in development that I'm really excited
about just sort of meeting Young new
creatives who have aligned sort of goals
and stories that we're interested in
telling um and then sort of work as an
actor as well that I'm excited about
approaching uh more produc orally too
awes well thank you so much for chatting
with us today it was so great to meet
you and get to know more about you in
the business opportunities that you have
on the horizon so thank you thank you so
much it so such a
pleasure